simplify xy to the negative 2 power
times 2x squared over y squared to the
fourth power so let's see what we can do
over here so let's think about this part
of our expression first if i have x over
y
to the nth power we know that this is
the same thing as x to the n
over y
to the nth so let's apply that right
over here 2x so this expression 2x
squared over y squared to the fourth
this is going to be the same thing as 2
x squared
to the 4th power
over
y squared over y squared to the 4th
power and of course we still have our xy
to the negative 2 power out here and
actually let me simplify that as well we
know that if we have we know that if we
have x times y
to the nth power this is the same thing
as taking each of the powers of each of
the x and the y and then taking the
product this is x to the n times
y to the n actually if you just expand
if you multiply x y times itself n times
you'll see why this actually works out
because you'll have x multiplied by
itself x times if you rearrange the
product and y multiplied by itself n
times so let's get so if we use that
same property here xy to the negative 2
that's going to be the same exact thing
as
x to the negative 2
times y to the negative 2.
now what can we simplify well we can use
this property again right over here we
have 2x squared raised to the 4th power
so that's going to be the same thing as
that's going to be the same thing as 2
to the 4th power
2 to the 4th power times
x squared to the 4th power and we can do
it in the denominator
y squared to the 4th power actually
we're going to use a different property
in the denominator we just have y
squared to the 4th power we know that if
we have x to the n
and then raise that to the nth power
this is the same thing as x to the n
times m
so y squared and then raising that to
the fourth power that's going to be
equal to y to the 2 times 4 power or y
to the 8th power
and of course out here we have x to the
negative 2 times y to the negative 2.
now let's let's think a little bit about
what x the negative 2 and y to the
negative 2 mean
x to the negative 2 just means 1 over x
squared y to the negative 2 just means 1
over
y squared so let's rewrite it like that
so this is
this is the same thing as 1 over
x squared times 1 over y squared so we
could just write that as 1 over x
squared
y squared that and that are completely
equivalent so let's see what we can do
now so we have one last thing
we could well we don't have one last
thing we have a few more things to worry
about we have x squared and then we're
raising that to the fourth power once
again we can use this property right
here this is going to be x to the 2
times 4 power so this part right over
here do it in a new color
this part right over here is going to
simplify to x to the eighth power two
times four
this part right over here is going to
two to the fourth power
two to the third is eight so two to the
4th is 16.
so that is 16. and so our whole
expression has now simplified and if we
multiply it times this we multiply it
times 1. so i'm going to multiply these
two fractions my numerator is 16
times x to the 8th
16 times x to the 8th and all of that
over
i have x squared i have an x squared
and then i'm going to have a y squared
times a y to the 8th what is y squared
times y to the 8th y squared
times y to the 8th we have the same base
so we can add the exponents we're taking
the product so it's going to be y to the
2 plus 8
or y to the 10th power so y squared
times y to the 8th is going to be y
to the 10th power and we're almost there
we have one more thing we can simplify
we have x to the eighth over x squared
and we know i'll just write the general
property if i have x to the m
over over
x to the n this is equal to x to the m
minus n power so x to the eighth over x
squared
that over there will simplify to
x to the 8 minus 2 power or x to the
sixth power and so our whole expression
has now simplified to
16 times x to the sixth
times x to the sixth
all of that over y to the tenth power
all of that over y to the tenth and we
are done